round eight of the u.s. Chess  Championships here in st. Louis  co-leader Wesley so could only draw his  game against akaru Nakamura  and although wins by two champions  Fabiano Caruana and Alexander honest  joke have them nipping at his heels  it was version Akopian defeating a  yaroslav's arabic who took the bull by  the horns to leap into a tie for first  with just three rounds to go reigning  Women's Champion Nagi for kids he drew  her game against the youngster Maggie  Fang and that left the door open for her  Olympian teammate sabina for to score a  victory in the ending and join aussie  atop the leaderboard  they are rounding the bend with  everything left to play for round 9  action coming up next